well thanks good to be here and uh i'm
uh feeling good and everything i had a
rough day today though i i bit my tongue
you heard that
[Applause]
and i got a big uh purpley thing on the
side of my tongue there and uh hurts
like a bastard you know and uh
and it's embarrassing you know it's
embarrassing but you're talking there
you know because you know you just you
know you're walking down a street there
minding your own business you know
you're just you know doodly dude
then you bit your tongue you got this
bit tongue going there and everybody
looking at you and
man that's bad
people go hey what's the matter there
wait what do you what happened to you
[Music]
they go what you what you bite your
tongue no
my uh uncle died
but uh i was thinking about today
actually i'm surprised that i don't bite
my tongue all the time you know because
i got uh so many teeth you know i got
like uh
i got 50 100 teeth in my head and uh
they're all right around my tongue you
know they're all
right near the vicinity of my tongue and
uh they'll bite anything my teeth they
don't care you know
could be a pork sandwich could be my
tongue what do they care they just bite
that's all they know
that's all they know they're not trained
for anything else they just bite
i get too many teeth that's the problem
i got like uh 1500 teeth and i only need
i don't know i never count them but i i
like to deal with round numbers but i
got a a lot of teeth
and i don't need hardly any of them you
know because a lot of them are like yeah
i got like uh i got fangs here you ever
see these teeth going here and a couple
you got big fangs sticking out which you
got no use for you know because
that's from back in the old days you
needed them back then to like whatever
you know
you know i mean you had to go out in the
morning and
stalk a gazelle and rip his throat out
with your teeth but uh you know you
don't have to do that anymore do you
thank god those days are over right
folks
remember back then when you had to wake
up
i should just take a pair of pliers and
pull out like i figure i only need like
maybe six teeth i tested it out on a
sandwich you know all i need i eat a
sandwich and there's like four or five
six teeth marks and that's it there's no
fifty hundred teeth marks
i lost the tooth back in the back of my
head and my dentist wanted to take it
out i said just leave it man i don't
need to grind the cornmeal or anything
like that you know you know where you
don't want to miss a tooth though you
ever see a guy no tooth up here in the
front oh that looks bad
oh man
you look like the stupidest guy in the
world you got no truth there
you could be the smartest guy in the
world but you got no tooth and people
just think that you're the stupidest guy
you know you could be the smartest guy
in the world talking to all the other
smart guys oh listen now other smart
guys listen as i tell you that and
people go hey you got no tooth there
what the hell are you talking about
take a look in the mirror hey hey ah
yeah
but
i take good care of my teeth you know
you got to take care of your teeth
that's what i i brush them you ever do
that sure yeah
everybody has what am i asking that for
i got uh trying to floss that's a tough
thing to get into that's a bastard that
flossing
oh my god you got a
got a rope there in between your teeth
and then after you're finished your
mouth's a big gushing fountain of blood
going there you know you're
yeah this feels good now i
yes
i feel a little faint but i got that
thing with the
i got that piece of pork from the pork
sandwich
so that's good i got that
sorry i don't floss the hell with floss
and i say you know
i do the next best thing you know what i
do i what i do is i tell my dentist that
i floss i just lied it again
the hell do i care he's just a dentist
you know
they don't care the dentist they don't
they don't know any better you know
he goes hey norm you've been flossing
lately like i told you there and i go
yeah yes
and he goes yeah yeah because i can't
help but notice all the plaque in
between your teeth there i can't help
but if i there's plaque all between your
teeth and i go oh
yes
well that's uh dennis that's because i
uh i my way over here to the dentist's
office on my way from the place where i
was i come over here i uh i stopped at a
i had a bowl of some i plaque i had to
vote a plaque
i had a big dish of plaque there they
had it down to the restaurant a big they
had a
half a pork sandwich and a bowl of
plaque that was special
then he goes all right fair enough there
you go
okay well i got no uh ending to that but
uh
god bless you folks